tonight what's up brother hey how's it
going rich can you hear me
yeah loud and clear man what do you got
for me tonight oh fabulous so
for this is when i was in my
early 20s the mid-20s i was in a
monogamous relationship for a little bit
this lasted for about three years or so
and during the time um at the beginning
it seemed all fine
until we had an argument uh pertaining
to i'm trying to recall this
this is a couple years ago so um
anyways the reaction of knowing knowing
that she had uh
all this mental issues she diagnosed
with something specific
um she she's on antidepressants and what
was the argument
so she i get a text and i just get in my
garage
and all of a sudden she
she's like brian this is the last time
you're gonna ever talk to me like
what does that mean like we break up or
something like that
and so i messaged her in the morning
like hey good morning
and she says brian and long story short
she tried to kill herself um taking
pills
so and
eventually that led to to an argument
and i never noticed it before but she
what was she diagnosed with like why is
she on antidepressants
um so because i wouldn't give her
antidepressants unless they diagnosed
her with something right
yeah and it was a whole slew of things
and and at the time she was going
through different ones i i don't quite
recall
um exactly the
um the exact uh
mental issue she was she was having she
also was getting treatments
from it's almost like a seizure
treatment like they're doing electric
shock therapy yeah
yeah her parents are multi-millionaires
like that they're
she's super hot or something like you
know you just look past that
yep no you're 100 correct um
her parents are like when when i first
went on a date she was like wearing
gucci and i'm like holy [ __ ] and mind
you i was
i just started my it was my first year
as an
automotive engineer um i'm here in the
greater metro detroit
um and i moved from actually
kind of by spokane washington where that
guy's from from north idaho and
ventured out you know um when i when i
graduated
and anyway anyways so
she's done like 20 something of these
electric shock therapies
which she had short-term memory loss
like there's a lot of times i need
to repeat myself and like a whole slew
of other things
and eventually she she started kind of
getting better but it's just like one
thing after another you're saying like
uh
emotionally draining just like little
things like oh you never talked to me or
whatever how long did you date her for
for roughly about three years yeah you
went through that for three years
yeah and i think that's attributed to a
little bit towards my childhood but i
but i don't think i want to be diving
into that just in the respect of
of being utilizing the time and the
subject matter
that i'm presenting and um
but and so i started kind of doubting
myself as far as like where i am on the
social hierarchy
as far as the sexual market value so i
did an experiment i was in florida for
three weeks
and so i added bumble and tinder just as
to see if
but like based on like the top 20 of men
get the swipes right and uh
i think i'm on bumble if i if i recall
right it
like you can swipe to i think 50 people
like per per day
anyways at the end of it all i had 300
some women within a three week
time period that liked me um
in that room okay okay let me stop you
there because i mean like the whole
thing with the pull in on this was like
you had an experience to share with a
woman that
that that had a diagnosis and was
also on ssris or antidepressants i want
to stay on that because it kind of
contributes to the topic tonight so what
advice would you give to
like what advice would you give yourself
if you could go back and talk to
yourself before you
entered that relationship with that
check okay yeah
um looking back at it now it's
knowing how she reacts if you get an
argument um
because sometimes there will be and on
top of that she was also sexually abused
from her previous boyfriend
yeah so the first time we ever had like
a sexual encounter
it was fine but i heard it the next day
and
almost making like sexual accusations
that like i
you know uh was forceful on her or
anything of that sort
and i'd be careful with that man exactly
you gotta be careful with stuff like
that and no
seeing all these red flags so from that
um but
like you're stating any body uh like
cuts
or any of that sort right i looked up
past that
and she had those um
she yeah the way she reacted like was
there
was there any accountability taken by
her for
for her results in life was there any
ownership taken
there actually was a few times like
because i'll stop talking to her when
she freaked out i was like
went cold-shouldered i'm not gonna talk
to you it's like when you wanna talk to
me and actually
uh so the accountability was taken when
you saw
nexter yeah and then did that did that
stay or did it go away when she resumed
the relationship
it it went away for uh okay so that's an
actor
okay so that's an actor okay so that's
that's that's pretty common with
borderline personality type of women
right
is they're they're hot they're cold they
make you feel like all of a sudden they
just get you sort of thing
you got to be really careful with that
have you read my book
i have yeah i just uh i read it um
pretty much the day after
you um had it on amazon okay good yeah
go through it again i mean there's stuff
in there that you probably need to
refresh yourself on but
um i'm going to move on because we're
because we're getting close you know the
wrap-up time but that's super important
to
consider too okay okay all right man
take care
you